tutti primo video mag bang per quello
non stiamo parlando a voce troppo alta
come sempre
allora indovinate chi è contento è
agitatissimo edith e otto ma allora li
abbiamo appena ricevuti però manca una
cosa è la prima volta che ci succede che
ordiniamo online e non si portano
qualcosa proprio oggi che dovevo fare il
video non ci hanno portato una cosa
comunque arriverà fra poco allora vi
facciamo vedere che cosa abbiamo prima
di iniziare a mangiare anche se vitale
sì ma non sarebbe tutto subito ingoiato
rossi aspetta allora sapete che fermo
sapete che siamo vegetariani quindi
abbiamo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12 ma
chi al l'avvocato poi abbiamo due
migliori con tofu fritto il topo un
ferito prof rito dall'esterno il riso
all'interno poi queste qui che vedete
sopra che sembra una verdure in realtà
sono delle foglie penso di non ne sono
sicuro o di insalata o cose basili lo
credo così rifritto quindi sono belle
krk ancora ma chi mette italiano e
dentro a avvocato di mitra mentre giorno
pare cetriolo cetriolo altro dentro
minimi di corto sono buonissimi questi
sono meravigliosi e poi stiamo
aspettando il resto che arriverà mai a
chi allora il microfono c'è mai nascosto
indovinate dove vediamo chi riuscendo
finali dove durante tutto il video è
affacciato possiamo iniziare o mangiare
iniziamo il nostro marchio benché la
società io sapevo già che sarebbe stato
difficile fare marco bang con vitale già
sta iniziando male
eccola qua
vitale usa b e allora vitale noi
giocando stem insomma ci chiamiamo lui e
cane e io sono gatto perché le nostre
personalità rispecchiano molto il cane e
gatto soprattutto lui avete presenti i
cani che mentre mangi ti fissano e
sperano che gli dai qualcosa da mangiare
ecco che tale e umane però io non è che
sto buono lì ad aspettare lui mangia
tutto io continuo a mangiare a una vita
normale non mi guarda con gli occhi da
cane come diceva qualcosa dal mio piatto
vabbè allora iniziamo dai macchina
boccato direi
buon appetito io devo trattare ma non
mette neanche lui sa di poter stare
allora che ne pensi
molto buono davvero buonissimo
l'avvocato è meraviglioso gli in bocca
[Musica]
un po che mi sapere se voi piacciono
se voi piace sfusi o se non vi piace o
cosa vi piace qual è il vostro sito
preferito dolore prende un altro
avvocato marchi quindi parliamo di cibo
mentre a me piace il management
certo sapevo che sarei stata io parlai
con la bocca piena
allora io guardo vari mag bank e mi
piacciono soprattutto quelli in cui
comunque parlano un po ci sono quelli in
cui le persone stanno zitte mangiano
basta oppure sì quelli noto hawking in
cui mangia mi basta proprio fisco quelli
in cui parlano perché sembra di essere
ospiti a pranzo a cena
oltre ai successi
buonissimi poi avevamo un sacco di rom e
quindi il mago band bisogna farli quando
in un sacco di far questo antipasto poi
dopo c'e tutto il resto è arrivata
l'altra parte del nostro ordine e poi ce
ne facciamo vedere allora questo fa e in
b tiri con il top lo faccio vedere
meglio
eccolo qua vedete c'è tutto il tofu
fritto attorno e sopra c'è il riso con
dei semi di come ti piace sempre
raffreddato purtroppo però sa fare un po
dolce nome social plus assino borsa i
modi di giorno c'è sempre un po
dolciastro se non sbagliano poi a me
piace a me gallina alla salsa di soia
problema per me invece l'opposto
pochissima salsa di soia ma io sono
particolari perché mi piacciono molto
anche lui usa b in genere was a me non
piace a nessuno
cioè raramente piace perché ha un sapore
super particolare sono assaggiate state
attenti potreste rischiare di affogare
perché è pesantissimo poi mi piace tanto
anche il ginger infatti con il wasabi
con mio cugino di una volta la prima
volta aveva mangiavamo insieme a cork
andato lì ha preso ma tu non li avevi
detto cos'era si chiude the usa b
provincia che non lo conosceva quindi
affatto così
mi stava sentendo male io poverino è
veramente molto pericoloso
comunque store e spegne li togliamo un
po visto che siete ospiti da noi
e allora ditemi se vi piace un imac bang
se ne guarda te qualcuno ogni tanto e mi
piacerebbe vederne altri ovviamente da
noi vitale sarà sempre appetitosi per me
sarebbe tutti i giorni pasqua per
cucinare qualcosa di buono soprattutto
questo lavoro buone se volete provare
del sushi vegetariano buono in genere
con la coccarda sempre buono però a
volte mettono cose tipo la carota eri
non sanno cosa inventarsi emettono la
carota e l'insalata
ma se fatti bene sono meravigliosi
allora qua asparago avvocato c3 è forse
spina anzi non solo potesse 15 lingue su
questo è buonissimo dobbiamo veramente
qual è il vostro sito preferito il tuo
lo sappiamo già
qual è il suo cile giochera non vivi un
po è a pizzo anche se ultimamente mi sta
piacendo meno la pizza mi piace cosa
aprile mamma guarda rimasta lo faccio
più mi piacciono non lo so c'è una cosa
che succede quando crescete che le cose
che odia volta quando eravate piccoli le
amate una volta che crescete ad esempio
quando ero piccola oppure
sono presenti anche quando avevo 8 anni
però non mi piacevano comunque le
verdure cioè alcune sì tipo la melanzana
le patate ovviamente le patatine fritte
team nella zona anche i funghi comunque
adesso mi stanno piacendo tantissimo le
verdure c'è tantissimo il broccolo ho
riscoperto testa fuori meravigliosi
delle verdure e si i minestroni che
passati di verdure oppure le zuppe che
c'era il broccolo mi piace tantissimo
poi cos'altro è che si piace un sacco la
melanzana la zucchi poi cambi un pò
gusti e poi diciamo che pensi di più a
quello che ti fa bene mangiare quando
sei un po più piccolo te ne freghi
proprio magico magari sempre pizza
sempre più importanti ne ho sempre dolci
zuccheri invece crescendo capisci che è
importante per aumenti quello che moggi
non solo perché ti fa bene comunque ti
fa vivere più a lungo stano non ti fa
ammalare
se non si bene ma anche perché ti dà a
molti quindi richiedono della giornata
in modo che puoi fare più cose se state
non sto facendo qualche progetto per
realizzare i vostri sogni se dovete
studiare
in generale del bie doppio energia
singer samercando sì infatti mi
raccomando ragazzi se adesso mi piace
solo le schifezze sin qui per un po se
però pensate si bene perché il cibo
noi siamo veramente quello che mangiamo
mi ricorda piccola leggevo questa frase
ruba ma io non sono una pizza
però sì poi crescendo capisci quanto è
importante mangiare bene e comunque ti
abitui perché se inizi a mangiare anche
tante verdure poi ti mancano davvero
sì abbiamo fatto questo discorso dove
mangiare stata poi abbiamo una coca cola
qua non la vediamo spesso per ogni tanto
ce l'ha con se diamo solo però a pranzo
tipo a cena mai se no dormiva le ha
quasi fatto qua poi possiamo passare
all'altra parte dell'ordine si cosa stai
guardando mai saltato tutto questo bando
è già finito la sua porzione ecco vi
ricordate quello che sto facendo qui ha
già finito perché non ha masticato ha
ingoiato tutto e adesso mi fissa potevo
fare scrivetemi voi non gioco più veloce
no fa male mangiare veloce mangiare il
piano fa molto menta per l'amico
sportiva mai tipico intenti a tratti
ringrazia gli stemmi di me ne prendiamo
un altro
trattasi infatti da questo lavoro noto è
lo facciamo un altro video di mach bang
solo per vedere me che mi mangia tutto
siamo da unità di prendersi al giorno di
ferie io faccio il video ma bang di 45
minuti e dove mangio per farsi capire di
che ne pensate
è lì sta intrattenendo bene dovete
scrivere 8 e 45 minuti nord mangiando le
imprese vi aspettiamo
aiutati alpinista di mangiare prima di
passare alla aspettiamo pazientemente la
vita decorati mise sempre così io mi
sento già osservata mentre manzo devo
mangiare questi mettere un mistero come
allora io parlo fisso d'oro non avanti
da mangiare dai la punta di essere
emozionato bellissima coppia
non vediamo l'ora di vedervi ci siamo
troppo contenti che finalmente abbiamo
la possibilità di vedervi tutti angelo
buonissimo e proviamo al punto davvero
non puoi scambiare ma questo non è il
mio come di salò non si posso credere
che stavo solo aiutando perché ho visto
che vedete va sempre a finire così
sempre ma ci sta vivendo tanto certo è
quello il problema pero ti do una mano
beh quindi l'ultima dai mangia fino a 31
immagini tinge quindi poi dopo non mi
darei la colpa buona rinfrescante
realizzo all'inizio emergenze faceva
schifo allora non vi piaceva proprio
strusci sempre vegetariano però poi l'ho
assaggiato fatto bene perché riuscì
dipende da quali assaggi perché può
essere terribile e può essere buonissimo
in base a dove
dove lo prendete se il ristorante buono
magari quelli non lo so se va bene
italiano gli stupidi sono anche
supermercato stesso forse che vanno
anche bene ma ti ricordi le volte quando
tornavo a casa dice avevo voglia di
ginger apprendevamo le buste di ginger
del milan che così tanto vengano le
volte proprio oppure che altre voglio a
bravo hai mangiato tutto vero no
cerimonia lo sa bene ragazzi
secondo round abbiamo qua delle verdure
come vi dicevo delle verdure come sono
fatte queste padella sono fatto erano
sulla piastra teppanyaki è una pasta
piastra di certo se non sbaglio molto
caldo e si mettono le verdure leggono un
pochino di oli che ci sono ci sono che
sembra la zucchina il porro i funghetti
bello bloccanti buonissima aiutato
sempre a darne ancona mangia più buoni
questi punti ha sede a essere un futuro
questo non sembrano funghi quindi vi
dicevamo dovete sporca con questo video
vi verrà voglia di alzare verdure in
genere quadro di mark bank vivier voglia
di mangiare quello che fanno mangiando
in versione sempre vegetariana
ovviamente perché vi farà venire voglia
di mangiare tante volte decorate quanto
sono succoso durissime siamo veramente
buona e saporita e fanno bene queste poi
tra l'altro si sono molto molto saporite
perché sulla salsa di soia quindi magari
un incentivo in più se volete se vuole
se volete provare a mangiare più verdura
trovate con la sala
la gioia
mentre c'è il pack cioe che un'apertura
che piace tantissimo la mia preferita
scrivete nei commenti
però appunto incentivare ancora di più
per parlare ancora di verdure qual è la
nostra verdura preferita splatter i
commenti e se vi piacciono i funghi
primi fungo il loro faceva sapere se un
dato senza avere un team fungo ottime
melanzana vinceva perchè non mi ricordo
di solito vinceva sempre di no c'è stato
un impegno di volta vi ha vinto timi
fungo timi melanzane una volta anche
broccolo o sbaglio non ho avuto mai brom
mi ha sorpreso una volta un parto
zucchina contro melanzana e ha vinto la
zucchina rimasta sorpresa proprio perché
pensavo che piacesse più la melanzana ma
se ci pensi la zucchina più dolce forse
la notizia come l'austria ma raiola però
la melanzana si può fare un sacco di tp
un sacco di modi tam anche lo zucchino
dei due diversi però non so io
preferisco la melanzana la zucchina
invece voi cosa preferite ma la zanus
china tutta due team fungo putin malazan
con questi rumori mentre mangiamo
sembrano di più ma non dopo il crac rock
che buono un ghetto
oppure vi consigliamo anche di provare i
noodles con le verdure da buoni colleghi
fantasia fa il cinese che al giapponese
noi tante volte ce li facciamo anche in
casa quasi tipo è uno dei miei piatti
preferiti e tipo almeno tre volte alla
settimana
sì ma torna però è bello non lo so mi fa
resto tanto contento se ancora ed ancora
che vi convinzione che vuole un altro
marchio bang chi lo sa che essendo
scrivetelo nei commenti parte dei
commenti indirizzato ed anita proprio
per dire guarda fai una seria con atto
una serie dove vitale mangia io direi
molto un altro sono avanti e basta certo
può già farlo nel tuo canale
ok allora mangia è ma decido io cosa sa
già come descrivere le cose vittoria e
sembra che lui non manchi mai in realtà
mangiano troppo chi sa per quale
profetizzando ma perché il ichino
mangiare ma non
va bene mangiare allora vitale mangia
troppo e poi si sente male
ecco perché glielo dico sempre ma pure
scusa non ho fatto
l'antipasto verdure allora poi parliamo
del firmware cuffie allora la prima
tappa sarà paese praticamente tutte le
città intendiamo non ne abbiamo viste
tranne roma ovviamente è solo la prima
volta vedremo barese che più piccolina
però ben 80
vedremo milano per la prima volta un
assurdo abbiamo girato altre parti del
mondo
io ho girato gli stati uniti un po gli
stati uniti all'italia un po che bruciò
infatti potrei vorrei citare molto più
dell'italia
comunque vedremo finalmente milano e un
po bruttina che da noi ci avete già
informato che fa tanto freddo
speriamo che stiamo meglio il tempo la
mia amica valentina allora io due amiche
che si chiamano tutte e due valentina e
tutte e due vivono a milano però una e
di milano e l'altra è di sassari come me
quindi ogni volta che valentina mi ha
detto quale valentina quella milano che
componiamo sempre comunque mi ha detto
che prossima settimana dovrebbe
migliorare il tempo più che bello quindi
magari troviamo il sole io ho paura che
a torino si stia rende terrificante
fatemi sapere se siete di torino
poi vedremo anche napoli per la prima
volta anche a torino per la prima volta
napoli e poi basta
l'uomo abbiamo visto tutto vero anzi se
siete di napoli
ovviamente vogliamo provare la pizza
napoletana si suggerisce c'è un posto
buono per andare a mangiarla scrive se
ci nei commenti in un posto il migliore
il top del top vogliamo provare la
migliore poi una cosa che proviamo un
poeta tipo ma io sì verranno la voglia
di mangiare sempre nucara non potremo
solo la pizza napoletana
credo che già non lo so è però credo che
a napoli la pizza sia un buon adatta sia
uguale per tutto atmosfera è la patria
della pizza prende adesso tutti i
napoletani giornalmente di vendita mio
tieni la zia sicilia salvatore
però attenzione perché a roma c'è anche
a roma la pizza la piazza romana quindi
un'altra tipologia in meno alto abbiamo
quindi quello ancora sulle verdure
mangeremo pizza per una settimana a
milano
non vedo l'ora di provare il risotto
ologrammi hanno pensato che
collettivamente però c'è questo posto
che si chiama of flowers burgers che li
seguo su instagram in pratica fanno dei
burger vegetariani vegani super colorati
loro coloratissimi ma non hanno
coloranti sono colori naturali che
facevano rosa che dal colore della
bietola e dicono tutti che sono
meravigliosi anno burger rosa celesti
gialli arancioni viola sono stupendi
quindi so che c'è a milano ma se non
fate sempre a roma però il romanzo un
altro po su cui vorremmo andare allora
vabbè comunque a milano vogliono provare
il flower burger spot si sapere nei
commenti se voi li avete mai provati dtc
di thesis mi sono piaciuti
non troppo curiosa e poi a roma questo
posto che si chiama romeo cat bistrot
in pratica in un ristorante lo stesso o
vegetariano o vegano o tutti e due
insomma che ha i gatti dentro come icap
caffè quindi nei bar in cui vai prende
un caffè e si sono i gatti dentro queste
pro ristorante con i gatti dentro già
troppo bello li segue su instagram è
vede sempre le foto dei gatti ci sono
dei bottoni bellissimi ovviamente sono
comunque dei gatti e ducati non è che
vanno e ti saltano sul tavolo come greco
si mangiano mentre stai mangiando sono
litro qui li dormono posteggiano che tu
mentre paesi a france a cena o che
questo colazione puoi stare con i gatti
accarezzarli secondo me un'idea stupenda
poi noi che adoriamo i gatti dovrebbero
fare sesso dog caffè potrebbero farlo
però penso che i cani si comporterebbero
diversamente angelo vista come 69 beh
secondo me è un idea geniale queste del
kutner strand romeo romeo e aveva detto
vederemo se volete vedere le moto le
foto su instagram rom mia o cat bistrot
e vedete le foto di tutti i gatti
stupendi oppure visite di roma potete
andare direttamente beati voi
e qui c'è un consumo del genere anche a
milano consigliato solo fateci sapere
riusciamo a prosciolto anche ho visto
che a milano si sono tipo i top
ristoranti vegetariani vegani c'è
proprio di tutto milano c'è un sacco di
scelta
per qualsiasi tipo di alimentazione
comunque c'è tantissima scelte del molto
bello avere questi stata scelta per
chiunque abbia delle esigenze
particolari o decida di non mangiare una
certa cosa è bello vuol dire che c'è
molto rispetto anche per per le scienze
degli altri allora abbiamo finito che mi
piace l'italia si faccia o tributo da
buon cane buone buone mi piace come mi
sono divertita a stare assieme a voi per
pranzo o cena
secondo quando state guardando questo
video comunque super divertente sembra
di avere ospiti a cena
se anche voi vi ha divertito e
ovviamente tu sempre masticando dice
magari facciamo una serie a cena con noi
bella idea di fare tutte le volte
ceniamo insieme e devi sempre cristina
rivale preferiti ecco ci sono diversi
mette un sacco di ieri a cena con vita
diventa cazzate allora ho potuto fare
nei commenti se vi è piaciuto questo
video mag se appunto che vorreste vedere
altri se anche poi vi siete sentiti
assieme a noi a tavola assieme a noi
e allora vi lasciamo con 4 capelli né su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video le nostre challenge spese
divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite